ん佐々あっはっは
やっぱ面白いなぁ
いろんな動画を全部見て最高な休みするぞ
あっこれは誠あ君と同じ小学6年生
卒業式を終え春休みを満喫中
みんな秋期講習で食育とか言って全然予定お話
中学のことは中学になってからやればいいなぁ
動画見まくったし糖分補給しに行きますか
んじゃ
買いに行きました亜裕美先輩
真じゃん元気にせいか
疎通の弘道先輩成績は隔年トップでサッカー部部長
hiromichi 先輩キラキラしてかっこいいなぁ
まあことももうすぐ中学生か勉強はちゃんとしてるか
や通学のことは入ってからでも何とかなるかなと甘すぎる
ばことが持っているこん平とより甘すぎる
得に中学は最初
がめちゃくちゃ肝心小学校の苦手を残しておくとヤバイぞ
中学の内容は小学校の内容とつながっているし中学はさらに難しくなるし一気に忙しく
なる
だから苦手は増えるし成績も茶水んだ
でも兄がてをなくすのはめんどくさいし
素直な奴だ
ああああああ
でもそんな面倒くさがり屋な誠におすすめなのはコレ
俺で小学校の苦手もなくなるし中学校最初のテスト対策まで5日でできるんだ
うわぁ
5日間なら俺にもできるかも
しかも ai 学習アシスタントか勉強をナビゲートしてくれるんだ
でも苦手な勉強ってちょっとめんどくさい
ガー
初めて症って知ってるかはじめしゃちょー面白くてみんなの人気者って感じですよね
でも僕と正反対って感じです
今はそうだよな
でも中学校時代は全然違ったんだってを実は目立つ何が出て勉強も苦手
イケてる中学生ではなかった手本には言ってたよ
本当ですか
そんなイメージなさすぎます
特に英語は苦手で100点満点中のですで12点だったらしいぞ
中に入ってそんなに勉強が苦手ななんて知らなかったですでも肇社長はここで諦め
なかったんだ
苦手な囲碁を徹底的に勉強したんだ
初めはできない問題も多かったでもあきらめずにやり続けたんだ
その結果
始め長は英語を得意科目にれきたんだ
授業では積極的に発言したり江東区10連発
だから今みたいに明るくてみんなの人気者になることができたんだ
真も苦手から逃げていたら中学
楽しめなくなるぞ
俺も
ちゃんと苦手を乗り越えてっ
中学いいスタートを切りたいです
まだまあ
僕もう一度真剣で見やりた
あんた前に貯めて辞めたじゃない中学校からみんな塾でしょ
きっ
進研ゼミはやってる人が多いんだよ
a 意外と多いのねでも中学入ってから様子を見てからでもいいんじゃないの
実際に見本を見ててきそうだと思ったんだ
今ならキャンペーンもやってて始めやすいし何より
早刷りのうちに小学校の苦手を乗り越えて中学でいいスタートを切りたいんだ
そこまで考えてたならいいわよまずは一ヶ月やってみましょ
[音楽]
じゃあ弄ってイエスあ
冷凍ございます
生
進研ゼニットがいたーーー
わー
私が豊臣秀吉のところ最後のテストで間違えたまあ
いちかさんか悩むけどさんかな
すごい大でも待ったからちゃんと復習ポイントも見ておかないと
[音楽]
武器を取り上げるのは方曲がりかないっ
今まで後回しにせたにがてもしっかりできるようになってきた
要点を1日目に確認したからスムーズにできたぞ
勉強は順調か
少しずつ苦手をなくせて気持ちいいです
第ファイトえっ
それじゃあ俺は練習行ってくるあ
すいません4つ理由
真頑張るよ
[音楽]
もうすぐ中学最初の新ユウセイですとか
中学のテストって難しいよなぁ
[音楽]
よし終わった
小学校の基礎が完璧じゃないと解けないから解くのが大変だった
あそういえば勉強以外の事も教えてくれるんだよなぁ
留学してるから友達ができるか不安なんだよなぁ
ん
友達の作り方教えて
疑問解消広場に友だちをつくるヒントが載っています
なるほどそこを見ればいいのか
高視聴率は
春休みを満喫しながら苦手をなくしてテスト対策まで出来たんだ
[音楽]
rar
雨やら準備できたが机なる無駄なものをちゃんとし前へストーン
開始
チェスト対策してなかったら混乱してただろうが苦手の単元も春休みに勉強したから
溶ける
あった
今回にゼスト満点だったのは1人だけはパーン
マホトを
すごいな満点だぞ
林美和てゼロにして良かった
みんなに褒められるって嬉しい
よーし勉強するぞ
[音楽]
よっし
ふぅ
を自分の目標点数や忙しさに合わせて問題を絞り込んでくれるんだよな
まずは僕の忙しさ目標
得意苦手
これが僕の学習プランかぁあ
翻訳機能が付いてるんだよなぁ
英語の宿題で使ってみよう
これはあなたのペンではありませんってなんて言うんだろう
[音楽]
ん
これはあなたのペンではありませんって英語でなんて言うの
this a pen
英語にも日本語にも訳してくれるし頼もしいなあ
すごいなぁ
あとわからない用語公式歴史の出来事を教えてくれる百科事典機能が付いてるんだよな
他の教科の子供聞いてみよう
ん家百姓ってどういう意味
百姓とは農民のことを指す語です
作翔って農民のことか
すぐ調べられるからどんどん復讐が進むな
[音楽]
立派
足かな問題わかりやすいるかー
これってゼミでやったけど数学苦手だからなぁ
[音楽]
ばことも苦手から逃げていたら中学
楽しめなくなるぞ
もう苦手から逃げないって決めたんだ
真わかるか
p
絶対値は3です
正解だしっかりを収集してきて広いなあ
[音楽]
てあげて応えるってこんなある死んだ
よし追い込むぞおお
チェストまでに必要な問題を絞り込んでくれるのか
[音楽]
そして俺は万全の状態で定期鉄に臨んだ
ままままパワー
[音楽]
やっぱよ高速10連発だよ原ワコとすごいじゃない
この調子でが終わってお小遣いあげるお菓子でも変えなさい
ありがとう
やったぁー
ああああああああ
ねえ
いいえ位
すいません
んとっ
ええん
肇社長は元気だな
ねええええ
やだが主で動画を撮ってたんだけど苦手いうのをイカを得るために頑張ってる公がい
るって聞いてさ
入った
あるやすいずっと頑張ってたもね
3が手を抜い超えるって大変だよね
どうやったらの声れるわからないしっ
肇社長でも苦手なことってあるんですね
うんっ
動画を撮影しててもにがてらって思うこともたくさんあるよ
でも村に勝手を乗り越えた先に楽しいって思う瞬間ってあんじゃないこと君もそうだっ
たんじゃないかな
すべては春休みから変わったんだ
あの時ちゃんと苦手をなくせる自分になれたから最高の中学スタートが切れたんだ
これからの中学生活でもたくさん苦手なことってでてくると思うけどその度に願った
ことを乗り越えて中学生活存分に楽しんでね見方のことを取り替えるたびに楽しいこと
が待っていると思ってあるさ
あっはぁ
あっはっは
3君を春休みの5日間で2月8をなくして中学
eta 製でスタートしよう
はじめしゃちょー
まってまってマッチ抹茶
はいというわけで今回は新減税中学校だ
ai が中アシスタント用スピーカーとのコラボでドラマ仕立ての動画にしてみたん
ですけれども自分の中学校時代を思い出しながら動画を撮らせていただきました
主人公の真への熱い想いで a 6ってみますちなみに中学校時代
12点だったのはがちです本当に12点でこれめちゃくちゃ英語2月だなぁと思い
ながらその後フィッシュに苦手な英語を勉強して今や
俺のパティー今日がになったという話でございます
苦手を乗り越えるのって本当に大変だと思うので皆さん t この進研ゼミの中学校
それにがてよ何か
売店みましょう錠剤は動画の代表欄を見てください
みんな中学校頑張れよじゃあなぁ
[音楽]
me
バッハ